Kanan god Jedi Jedi Order
this is Master obi-wan obi-wan Kenobi
this message is a warning and his
surviving judges award dark shadow this
is a warning
the Empire is hiding something something
important we'll deal with it they can't
keep it hidden forever
I just hope it won't be too late there's
a rebels behind AMI
codenamed welcome we're building an
alliance this is our rebellion
attacked by multiple rebel cells is
unprecedented they revealed their media
defenses and it's exactly this moment
I've been waiting for welcome home I
should let them know we're coming so
they don't shoot us down that's funny I
wait you're not kidding hi your rebel
friends are going to bring the empire
down on all of us if you can convince
your mother to help the rebels all of
Mandalore might follow you in the dark
saber once people know you have it you
will be challenged you must use all your
skills together
I'm fighting for you and everyone else
not to lose what they've got
my friends make the impossible possible
plus some buckets
we will show the galaxy what happens to
those who dare speak against the Emperor
not a [ __ ] help it
we'll never surrender to you Ron I'm not
accepting surrenders
I want positive you crash into an
Iranian
you're in the wrong place
hey youtubers it's Charlie so everyone's
freaking out obi-wan Kenobi Darth Maul
rematch maybe a Luke Skywalker teaser so
let's break it down even though rogue
one is already out just because the hype
for episode 8 is picking up I'm gonna go
ahead and keep the Star Wars giveaway
going is for IMAX gift certificates all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so let's start with the biggest stuff
first number 10 obi-wan Kenobi on Star
Wars rebels if you didn't know like you
see him he's a little bit older than he
was before in the message when Ezra's
hearing the message from the holocron
that's from order 66 at the end of
episode 3 so that's like a recording of
this version of obi-wan Kenobi much
earlier in the timeline this takes place
in the years before rogue 1 now they
didn't say exactly how many years but
it's probably just a couple like very
close to when rogue one happens but if
there was any question rogue one happens
after this in then Episode four so
that's the order
but obi-wan Kenobi you're in the wrong
place bro in it's Darth Maul so Darth
Maul versus obi-wan Kenobi that's gonna
be so awesome
but number 9 I would be willing to bet
that this is the season when they
finally end Darth Maul because we know
as of the original trilogy he's not
alive anymore so at some point he will
meet his end during this series but
because of the arc that Ezra is on Ezra
is probably going to be the one to kill
him I don't think the obi-wan Kenobi
would kill him but we got a hardcore
rematch on our hands remember number 8
the last time they faced off obi-wan
Kenobi chopped him in half and threw him
down a shaft and that was the last we
heard of him till he came back during
Clone Wars with the help of some
technology in the Nightsisters
revenge I must have revenge so if you've
rewatched the Star Wars movies recently
and you want to go from like episode 3
to now the Darth Maul Clone Wars
episodes explain how he came back in
where he came to now but they're
actually much older now so it's like old
Darth Maul versus old obi-wan Kenobi so
it's very much in the tone of that
obi-wan Kenobi versus Darth Vader scene
on the Death Star
like two old people who haven't seen
each other in a long time that have a
lot of history together
but obviously Darth Maul's history with
obi-wan Kenobi is all bad he killed his
master qui-gon so it's not like they
used to be friends or he used to be his
Padawan or something like that
number eight though the dark saber so if
you're not current on Star Wars rebels
the dark saber is another callback to
the Clone Wars
he was wielded by a Mandalorian general
that tried to seize power went a little
bit nuts obi-wan Kenobi fought him for
he spent a lot of time on Mandalore
helping out Satine who was the Duchess
of Mandalore remember that was like the
big romance of obi-wan Kenobi there's a
lot of theories that Rey from the new
trilogy might be his granddaughter
through Satine but just you know all
speculation at this point so wide open
to theorycrafting
but the dark saber is an ancient weapon
as you can see it's kind of like a light
saber but Sabine is using it to unite
the Mandalorians who have been fractured
so if she can wield it successfully and
hold it then you can see that they're
trying to get them to join the rebellion
so this all comes back around to rogue
one stuff number seven as of rogue one
when the rebel fleet meets the Imperials
at Scarab it's basically all of the Mon
Calamari and you can see some Inklings
of a wings X wings but they haven't
quite got to that point as of right now
and rebels so you're slowly seeing a
bunch of rebel cells come together to
form what is the Rebel Alliance as you
can see number six Admiral Thrawn feels
like he has it all in hand he's the
master tactician he has that real badass
training scene where he just laying into
all those battle
droids just going crazy they're just
presenting him as this total badass that
knows way more about the rebels then the
rebels know about themselves like he
knows them better than they know
themselves and he has the full resources
of the empire at his disposal so number
five the desert planet this looks a lot
like Jed ha
from rogue one and because we have saw
Guerrera
that means that we might be seeing a lot
of the same stuff that we saw during
broke one they're doing a lot of rogue
one characters they even mentioned
number four fulcrum in casseon and or
from rogue one was confirmed to be one
of the fulcrums but he could show up on
rebels too if they're gonna do obi-wan
Kenobi they've done Leia they've done so
many original trilogy characters it
would make sense that more rogue one
characters would come on - speaking of
which
right now the Death Star is being
constructed number four now how is it
being constructed in secret without the
rebels knowing about it we've had like a
couple seasons of Star Wars rebels we
haven't seen too much of it but the way
that the Empire kept it secret was by
compartmentalizing a lot of its
construction operations doing it in a
remote sector of space where they could
control the traffic but this is really
interesting and kind of gruesome but the
G&O 'sons who were responsible for
designing the Death Star were
essentially wiped out like they
committed a mass genocide of their bug
race so that is a giant bug hunt just to
keep the Death Star secret and if you're
wondering why they didn't tell us that
in the movies it's just because they
want to keep a little bit of that for
the expand of materials but as of right
now the gia no sense no longer exists
anywhere they were completely eradicated
in the way that the Empire tried to
eradicate the Jedi Order in fact
actually now that I think of it this
desert planet might actually be Geonosis
because like looking at the episode
titles it just says ghosts of Geonosis
so that looks like where this is so
they'll probably find out about the
genocide then but what about Kanan he's
been training with the Bendu who
practices both light side and dark side
force skills he is turning into
something of like a super Jedi so in the
way that obi-wan Kenobi also learned to
become a force ghost I wouldn't be
surprised if Kanan starts to
some of that stuff this season - but
he's just becoming more and more
powerful even though he's lost his sight
you lose one of your senses but
everything else gets heightened like I
said number two the big thing I think
that Ezra is gonna be the one to kill
Darth Maul and that'll push him even
more towards the dark side I can't wait
to see how they changed the cannon to
explain where he shows up during the
original trilogy because he's such a big
figure now there's so much story behind
him that they have a lot of explaining
to do but number one though is obi-wan
Kenobi on this desert planet which seems
like Tatooine makes me wonder if we'll
get a teaser for Luke Skywalker coming
on the show eventually so just because
they bring everybody from the original
trilogy back on the show doesn't
guarantee Luke Skywalker but I
definitely think it's a possibility
because Mark Hamill does so much voice
acting for animation that I totally
think he would be down to try and do a
younger version of himself as Luke
Skywalker but because this is happening
before Episode four we're talking about
like 14 15 year old Luke Skywalker but
let me know what you guys think of the
trailer and let me know if you think
we're gonna see Luke Skywalker on rebels
but what's gonna happen next is I have
some new flash season 3 so that'll be
the next video to post what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn all about that Darth Vader
scene in rogue one and you can click
here for all my rogue one Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]